ecuador enfrenta múltiples desafíos bajo
la presidencia de guillermo lasso el
país es uno de los más afectados en
américa al inicio de la pandemia se
encuentra sumido en una crisis tanto
sanitaria como económica para el nuevo
mandatario la vacunación es clave y por
eso se trazó el ambicioso objetivo de
inmunizar a 9 millones de personas en
sus primeros 100 días necesitamos que
los ecuatorianos salgan de sus casas
recuperen la normalidad vivan con
tranquilidad vayan a sus empleos puedan
emprender y también puedan en las noches
ir a los lugares de diversión de
esparcimiento y de esas formas de
reactivar la economía en 2020 la
economía ecuatoriana se contrajo un 7 8
% la caída más profunda en décadas el
país cuenta con una deuda nacional de
unos 70 mil millones de dólares un
tercio de la población vive en la
pobreza y aunque el desempleo formal es
del 7% gran parte de la población se
encuentra en condiciones de subempleo o
trabajo precario
además se cuenta con acceso limitado al
financiamiento externo luego de recibir
7500 millones de dólares por esa vía en
2020 y ahora espera de renegociar los
2.500 millones que restan del préstamo
del fondo monetario internacional
en este complejo escenario y para
disminuir el déficit fiscal
laso ha propuesto reducir el gasto
público elevar la producción petrolera
dar incentivos a la inversión extranjera
combatir la corrupción y crear al menos
un millón de empleos propuestas
ambiciosas que pueden chocar con su
escaso apoyo en la asamblea nacional con
solo 12 de 137 escaños el nuevo gobierno
deberá negociar para sacar adelante sus
proyectos un escenario que ya encontró
su primer traspié luego de rechazar un
acuerdo tripartito con el partido
socialcristiano aliado en las elecciones
y la principal fuerza opositora la
alianza un es que agrupa el correísmo
nunca prepare que se une a eso de
ecuatoriano y sus últimos anhelos como
moneda de cambio en un trueque de voto
con mayoría de mujeres al frente de las
áreas sociales de su gabinete lazos
prometido también una lucha sin tregua
contra la violencia de género enfrentar
la delincuencia organizada y la crisis
carcelaria y respetar la independencia
judicial han sido otras de las metas
trazadas por el mandatario conservador